- [Instructor] We are asked
what fraction is located
at point A on the number line?
And we can see point A right there.
Pause this video and see
if could answer that.
All right, now there's a bunch of ways
that you could think about it.
You could see that the
space between zero and one
is split into one, two,
three, four equal spaces.
And this has gone three
of those four equal spaces
from zero to one.
So that's one interesting
way to think about it.
Another thing that might help us
is a bit of a visualization.
If this rectangle represents a whole
and notice it goes from zero to one,
so you could view one as a whole,
we have split it into four equal sections.
So each of these equal sections
you would consider a fourth.
So that's a fourth right over there.
That's another fourth right over there.
This is another fourth right over there.
So how many of these
fourths have been shaded in?
Well three of them have been shaded in.
And when you look at the number line,
you see the same idea.
When we see the space between zero and one
it has been split into fourths.
So this is a fourth,
and then another fourth,
and another fourth.
And where is point A?
Well we have gone 1/4, 2/4, 3/4 past zero
or from zero to one, which is a whole.
So what fraction is located
at point A on the number line?
3/4.
Let's do another example.
So here we're told which point
is at 2/6 on the number line.
Pause this video and see if
you can answer on your own
before we work through it together.
And I'll give you a little bit of a hint.
Let's imagine that this
rectangle represents a whole
and notice it is divided
into six equal sections
so each of those sections is 1/6.
And so if I start at zero,
how many would I fill in
to get 2/6?
And what would be the corresponding point
on the number line?
All right, now let's do it together.
So if each of these is a sixth,
and we have 6/6 there
so that would be a whole
and that's good because
it goes from zero to one
and you can view one as a whole.
2/6 is, so that's 1/6 right over there
and then that is 2/6.
And so you can see on the number line,
the thing that gets us 2/6 of
the way to one is at point B.
It corresponds to how much
we've filled up that rectangle,
point B right over there.
Now another way that you
could think about it,
you could see that the
space between zero and one
is split up into six equal sections.
One, two, three, four,
five, six equal sections.
And we want to go to 2/6.
2/6.
So each of those equal sections,
we are increasing by a sixth.
So we're going from zero to 1/6 to 2/6.
Once again we end up at point B.